[Music]
why would the banks disrupt themselves
by introducing a digital currency that
would make it easier for consumers and
businesses to disintermediate the banks
well the banks may not be the innovators
it may be that they are the reactors
that they will react when others
innovate and I'm sure that they
considered the trade-offs involved in
whether to disrupt themselves by
introducing digital currencies or
whether to wait and react when others
introduced digital currencies right now
digital currency sounds very edgy and
kind of alternative lifestyle but it's
it's becoming the mainstream and so the
banks the largest banks in particular
are very aware of this they're investing
in the technology and they will provide
this service as soon as it's profitable
enough after considering the costs to
them of losing some of their current
business that they're going to disrupt
banks will eventually either be leading
or following that they'll be involved
they can't avoid it
[Music]
you
[Music]
you